what's going on it's Juwan Alejandra
we're a black Odyssey catches on the
bootleg kind of podcast appreciate that
the plan
bootleg cat podcast special guests here
black Odyssey what's good man welcome I
gotta admit something to you guys I
didn't realize you guys were like a
group I just thought you were black
Odyssey it's kind of like an atmosphere
type thing yeah bro like they're Slug
and ant and there's so black Odyssey is
a
yeah it's a Duo it's a Tucson yeah
I heard they call you guys the gruesome
twosome why I've never heard that in my
life
so how long has black Odyssey been a
thing
since 2015. so 2015 you guys did you
guys meet in Austin yeah yeah yeah
um started as a rock band together I was
working in the village he was working in
the pizza shop nice and I was going in
there getting which pizza spot was it
was it like on six somewhere nah it was
kind of out like in the bushy part of
Austin like you guys would you consider
yourself I know you guys aren't from
Austin you're from Florida you're from
Jersey yeah yeah but you guys have been
there for almost a decade right so you
guys have probably seen the like crazy
growth facts 2015 was like Peak good
South by year Well towards the end of
the great the Great South by yours but
um is is it kind of crazy to see the
growth of tech like Austin is wild like
I just think like where fader Ford is
there's like a Whole Foods and a Target
now
like it's kind of wild like what do you
how do you guys feel about like seeing
that growth in in the city that you know
you guys call home because it is like
especially during the pandemic I feel
like everybody moved there
I mean it should to me has been
interesting because we've seen like the
economic development in the city blow up
crazy but as for musicians the the
infrastructure for industry there has
been stagnant the whole time through so
it's been interesting to see it grow
side by side and how much like the music
industry has got pushed out of Austin
since you know the economic development
went crazy
um so that has just been a super
interesting perspective in general
because we think like Austin's like a
live city or a live music city right
right right right but now it's like
comedies there there's all this Tech
[__] going on like no yeah rent's
probably going up huh
is it yeah how many times have you guys
ate uh barbecue in an alley off of a
trash pail
really you don't like barbecue
I liked it the first year I moved there
I feel like I've been in an alley eating
off of a trash can lid like 17 times and
I don't even live there this is I'll
gain like 30 pounds when I moved to
Texas I used to be fit
well you're not like fat yeah I'm
getting there though me and you are both
getting there
I like the jacket it hides the getting
there I wear xlos now so break down your
guys's roles when it comes to Black
Odyssey
um so I approached Alejandro
um who's a guitar player yeah yeah like
I mentioned we started as a rock band
and that was the name
was the name black Odyssey when you guys
were in the band or you didn't have a
name okay I was going by Sam Houston at
the time okay it's [__] up but I was
going by Sam Houston with the band
behind you yeah okay
um so um I had these tracks I'm a
producer
and a songwriter but it lacked in live
um instrumentation
so um I was trying to type in with some
people in town that that could bring
that element
and um his his the way he plays guitar
adds a different live element to the
records that goes further than just
guitar playing
um it's almost like using your
instrument to you know achieve different
production things that you can't really
do in the box so right yeah yeah you
shred
Shrek but like Soulful shred Soulful
Shredder and just like like you said
atmospheric and like kind of making the
guitar just like a Production Tool right
and that's definitely evolved as we've
evolved you know you guys have like had
some big Legends on records like George
Clinton Bootsy Collins obviously that's
pretty crazy
how do you end up making something like
that happen
man the commonality between because we
came from two totally different worlds
I'm from Plainfield New Jersey right
that's what um Parliament Funkadelic
started okay
um and he came from Like a Rock
background so I didn't know anything
about Rage Against the Machine or I
thought Led Zeppelin was one person type
[__] like [__] shout out to Black
Odyssey
so like yeah man like I learned about
that you know world of music and in turn
I was showing him D'Angelo and I was
showing him all that kind of [__] so
um
we always had a common appreciation for
like Funk and like psychedelic music and
that was George Clinton and and Bootsy
Collins
do you get like kids no cousin who knows
them or like how do you get like I feel
like those aren't the easiest guys to
get a hold of yo that ass we were on We
Were Here on a trip this is George
Clinton right and um
I seen a we had been like talking to our
label and our team for a while about
trying to type in with him
um and everybody was like brother it's
[__] George Clinton like you can't
just call him right so how it works
right thanks so uh I seen a video of him
here for uh Red Hot Chili Peppers
and I showed him and I was like yo let's
go down there and just go cold up and
tell him and talk and we laughed at all
because we wasn't serious
but we're shopping on Melrose that same
day
and his [__] just walked by us in this
[__] like silver trenched like yeah I
didn't even notice who it was at first
I'm like that's a funky ass outfit did I
look and he's walking behind me and I'm
like yo that's that's George Strait just
walking down Melrose bro it was nuts
like and that's what I'm saying it has
to be God you know I'm saying so he's
walking past and I look at all the
holidays and I'm like I'm not really the
type of [__] that that's just like wait
for a celebrity to talk to him right but
I'm like I I have to do this you feel me
right
so he went into the store and was
shopping
and I just waited outside like I was
going to phone calls Captain I wasn't on
the phone I just wanted to see Norma so
I was waiting on the phone and as soon
as he walked out I acted like I saw him
by mistake and then I went up to him and
I started you know talking and
he didn't he wasn't very responsive like
I told him I was from Plainfield and I
told him like I knew some people in his
family and [__] and he just kind of was
like yeah yeah right and he just he just
he yeah I told him I wanted to work on a
record with him right
um and I didn't like I was like that
that's not how I thought that was going
to turn out it didn't go well in your
opinion at the time no not at all it
didn't it didn't seem to do anything two
weeks later I told him who we were I
told him the name
um
and his daughter was with him too so I I
said you know the name to his daughter
um two weeks later she DMS me on
Instagram out of nowhere
she's like yo George George is down to
do a record which I would play to me and
[__] he hears the similarities like oh
[__] that's what you're doing yeah
George is down to do a record
so we sent him the record that day
hopped on FaceTime and he's pretty much
cooler on FaceTime yeah
my dad used to follow him back in the
70s so I told him all that
and
yeah it was nuts bro your dad would go
to like shows and [__] yeah he would
just follow them on the road with my mom
really yeah your parents must have been
raging high as [__] doing all the good
drugs all of them bro all of them it was
nuts peyote shroom peyote it peyote is
like a you know it's like a
to I think it's a cactus right yeah
that's crazy you eat it and you trip
balls oh [__] yeah that's what they eat
I feel like that's what they used to do
peyote yeah the Mothership Connection
it's a Mothership Connection
um what about Bootsy Collins
um we just we DM George and we were like
yo do you know Bootsy or I mean do you
know his number or can you connect me I
can connect you for sure no no I'm
saying like is that what you asked like
hey thanks for doing the song by the way
can you connect us with Bootsy literally
yeah I was like yo can you connect me
with Boosie
um he was like yeah got you just give me
a few days
he he did a DM connection and
um shout out George bro huge I'm telling
you like this is so much love
so he connected us and hit us right he
hit his back right away relatively and
he was like yeah I'm down
I think six months went by between
responses and we had pretty much figured
like that he wasn't gonna do it right
um do it meaning married the whole
record and [__] like that
um and as we were wrapping up the record
we had already typed in with Keisha punk
from Griselda okay to to to be the
narrator of our of our concept album
um and we had figured that that Boosie
wasn't going to do it because they had
they hadn't responded in six months but
as we're getting ready to go into mixing
for the record he hits us and he's like
yo y'all still want me to do this I can
I can do it like tonight
so yeah that [__] just fell in our laps
he just sent it right back
uh are you are you buddy are you like
pretty hip to all the rap [__] cause you
guys getting Benny The Butcher on
records and like you know
I just evolved as a person especially
since moving to Austin right you know
because Panama City as you know Southern
Alabama right just uh you know not as
exposed over there like [__] Gator
Guns out there yeah
absolutely bro there's some getter done
in Austin though I think people forget
Austin's in Texas sometimes you're in
Austin you're like oh this is this
City's A vibe and then you like leave
and you're like oh
there's some other [__] going on here
that's what I think it's cool about them
though like he doesn't give a [__] we
could be that roll with Freddie using
the room with Freddy I don't even think
he really knew who he was and he was
like what's up bro exactly yeah what do
you do yeah yeah I think that school is
fun
um who's in charge of the artwork
because your guys's artwork is super
dope it's very consistent in terms of
like colors and I feel like Vibe like I
think that's like what caught me
initially was just like oh [__] like
because I feel like that's kind of like
your first impression for anybody you
know is that is that do you handle that
you guys handle that together that's us
collectively my manager over there like
it's something we all sit down as a team
and look at like we we discuss what we
want to like capture and and still and
um like we brainstorm on different ways
to do it you guys set up photo shoots
for that and then just go through a
bunch of options and yeah for sure yeah
so this this particular album cover
um it's like an erotic novel so we
wanted to like capture the the the
the picture of like lusting and like not
being able to escape your addictions
right in the still frame so so that's
the theme of this new album thanks yeah
erotic have you guys ever read any
erotic novels that's a point of
reference never never I've seen 50
Shades of Gray now yeah yeah that's all
I need terrible movie really bad like
all time badly so many [__] in there
though so I was like I'm gone
yeah definitely for the theater but the
theaters definitely I just I can't speak
to the movie it was I was expecting a
lot because the book was so popping
right no that [__] was cheeks bro that
was weird what's worse 50 Shades of Gray
or the weekend's new show
I didn't see that I saw this clip of him
being tough earlier
I just watched the first episode a
couple days ago and I love the weekend
and I hope it gets better but the first
episode was crazy what is it called the
Idol idol yeah but
early episode it was
Fifty Shades of Gray right wow that's
right that's right tie it all in yeah
that's what that's what really got me
into the weekend for sure really oh yeah
but then I chose to just yeah we went
look at you reverse that's what I'm
saying man it's all exciting all right
you already know man we gotta stop the
interview shout out to my bookie right
now if you go to my bookie and sign up
man I was just playing roulette like
live
with a real person spinning the ball on
webcam at the casino mybookie.ag
you can of course bet on baseball
but really you got to get down with the
casino they got the slots they got all
the card games Blackjack cracks uh
roulette table games galore it's a
full-fledged casino mybookie.ag and when
you sign up with that promo code bootleg
sign up right now use that promo code
bootleg they're gonna get you hooked up
with a first deposit bonus mybookie.ag
let's get back to the interview now if
you guys don't know about King pong
kingpong is all natural baby yes all
right we're talking about the leader
when it comes to uh tobacco-free natural
organic Leaf wraps if you're a smoker a
toad or a straight west coaster you know
what I'm saying whatever you're into
King Palms they got it for you what's
great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying and then you got
flavor I'm going to show you what it
looks like when it's stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
all right get that thing stuffed up the
tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms maybe you already know what
it is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save
50 off at checkout half off at checkout
50 off if you go to kingpom.com and use
that promo code the promo code is down
below go run it up try some of these
flavors too man the peach pineapple the
Strawberry Shortcake they just got so
much going on there's also all kinds of
dope smoking accessories you can get
half off y'all what are we talking about
save 50 off kingpom.com promo code below
it's either bootleg or bootleg have them
these promo codes got my head hurt try
both of them all right one of them get
you 50 off God damn it anyway let's get
back to the interview what's it like not
being black and being in a group called
black honesty
I mean I'm Cuban so like right but not
black
you're not afro-cube
deep deep in the spirit okay you know
like I approach life with like soul and
like you know I mean you have to feel
like you black on the inside too bro I
mean I I don't know I I bought An
ancestry kit I gotta spit in the tube
and send it out yes
I'm definitely a lot of Europe or
Ireland I think I'm Irish
German I thought Italian for some reason
I mean I could be wrong I have no idea
polish
I dated a police girl in high school her
dad was so [__] racist that sounds
about right yeah yeah that's crazy
what's your manager over there he looks
like he could be from [__]
Scandinavia
that [__] looks like he's
related to Nicola jokic bro he looks
like he just want a chip over there
me and him grew up together we were in
music school in sixth grade shout out to
Jersey yeah bro how far is uh what part
of Jersey is it Plains where's that in
terms of like where The Sopranos took
place and then New York City uh that's
about 40 minutes from Bergen County
where The Sopranos took place and then
there's like because I've only been I
just was in uh where did we go to shoot
with um what's that kid's name just got
out of prison that we shot a shot with
in Jersey
[__] I'll be I'll he's on Empire yeah
I'll be y'all
yeah we were in some some neighborhood
in Jersey
well we're uh Jersey City or Newark or
some [__]
I lived in Newark for a long time I
definitely texted drusky when I was
there and I'll tell you right now
because I was like I'm in Jersey is he
is he from Jersey
yeah which Drew ski are we talking about
I was in a Jersey City Jersey City
is that where we were
yeah Jersey City pretty wild out there
there was like a small it was a
different area we were in there
oh yeah he took he took uh well and he
took uh he bought a honey pack right did
he put the honey pack in the honey bun I
don't know if he did that you guys ever
have a honey pack no I don't even know
what that is really what is a honey pie
from the gas station it makes your dick
hard
a magic honey you know what else makes
your day card Bluetooth go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
bootleg right now sign up you get a
month supply for free I've been seeing
that [__] same active ingredient as Vira
and Cialis and if you use the promo code
bootleg right now you get 30 days for
free that's amazing that was crazy that
was like The Truman Show yeah
well you know if you go to the gas
station they have like the magic packs
of honey
and then they also have like the Rhino
pills the Blue Rhino I don't be in that
section it's it's that's where you check
out yeah like the horny goat weed and
all that all that [__] no it's the it's
the magic honey
really I should have you look if you're
like drinking and you're like look you
know I'm a little drunk I might have
whiskey dick this might not work you
just or you go to bluetooth.com keep a
blue trolling deck and use the promo
code bootleg and get a month supply for
free
yo
[Laughter]
um that is crazy I was gonna say for you
like uh you know because because the
Benny record what came out last year
right the last hour
um what's it like getting on a you know
kind of getting one of the elite MC's in
this [__] to to bless because that's the
record George was on too right yeah yeah
what was that process like you guys are
both obviously I guess well he's on Def
Jam now but you know label Made issues
all right thanks yeah I mean the Common
Thread is definitely Mima like he's he's
[__] damn near Steve Nash at this
point bro like definitely a Steve Nash
type of guy yeah he's crazy like
um I linked up with Benny and we had
just followed each other on Instagram
and we have spoke
um both East Coast [__] so I feel like
the the Synergy was already there
um but once Nema got involved and just
made it happen it was pretty easy he did
it real quick he killed it you're pretty
big on a lot of the Griselda [__] all of
it yeah yeah Conway is probably my
favorite there Benny Conway's my
favorite everybody I mean I love all
those guys but Conway's [__] [__] rap
his ass off bro and he like makes you
feel like you're like damn I want to
produce for him um that's that's
probably the main person I want what do
you produce on
logic yeah so you've been doing that for
a minute because I feel like anybody who
does [__] on logic like that's what they
learned on and that's just what they're
on like I can't move I started in 2015
and I looked at Ableton and that [__]
looked like [__] airplane yeah
Ableton Ableton like I feel like when
you look at Ableton it looks very
intimidating right yeah it just doesn't
make sense the interface to me like you
know yeah everything exactly it doesn't
make sense to me at all yeah like logic
makes sense facts yeah Pro Tools make
sense even even Fruit Loops you'll look
at it and you'll be like oh I see what
they did there
you'll see Fruit Loops and you'll be
like I see it I get it no but Ableton is
the one where you're the cycle this [__]
looks like [__] yeah it doesn't make
sense trigonometry bro yeah you know
what I mean like physics
no you do so much on anything like I
feel like if I learned how to use it I
would be such and then I don't
understand the touch thing like there's
like the big thing they sell and it's
just got 800 buttons what do I do with
this no yeah it's not practical no and
I'd be seeing like shots of the people
on Tick Tock shooting fake producer
videos you're [__] NPC ain't hooked
up you're full of [__] you're just
pressing buttons the Beats already been
made yeah you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah and then there's the DJs
who like there's nothing plugged in like
what are we doing here like bro I ain't
gonna lie I've done that a couple times
with the Beats I did a DJ set where the
whole [__] was done in logic already oh
you just press play just press play and
I was up there on my Denzel [__] it goes
but you know what that's at least I
respect that because you at least put
the set together yeah oh the transitions
was crazy and a lot of um a lot of the
bigger EDM DJs that's what they do but
they do it in Ableton oh yeah yeah yeah
I've watched like I won't say their
names but like in Vegas I've watched
like some of the biggest
DJs in the world just their computer is
an Ableton session yeah and they just
press play and they have their movies
with knobs yeah hey
look
yeah uh you guys got any tour stuff on
the way yep we start in September doing
us and Europe Canada are you guys
excited to go out yeah sure that's where
we Thrive for sure so is it just YouTube
do you guys bring a full fullback full
band yeah I feel like the full band is
definitely like especially it's got to
be the key man because I feel like when
I first saw the roots I was 12. wow and
I was like this is the crazy show I've
ever seen like a hip-hop band like you
know I mean obviously there's been more
incarnations of that since I was 12. but
at the time when I was 12. It was kind
of crazy to see right yeah so I love to
see the younger like kids feel that for
the first time when we dropped black
vintage a lot of those kids [__] with
it a lot in this reminiscent of outcasts
and Kendrick so they came to the show
but they hadn't they have been going to
other shows so they hadn't seen like of
Us come out and they're doing full
orchestrated you know run through the
whole show so I was gonna say for the
type of music you guys are making I feel
like there's definitely like a huge Lane
now as to where maybe when you first
started or even like three or four or
five years ago it was kind of like an
underground Niche Lane as to where now
like guys like the soul action radio
guys have kind of there's like this Lane
of just like great soulful music that is
finally kind of coming to the Forefront
you know what I mean we're still trying
to find our tribe too bro like it's
difficult with this kind of music
because it's not applicable to like the
quick [__] like Tick Tock is it's not
gonna work there
um and like it's it's not necessarily
like prone to go viral it's definitely
something that people have to you know
ingest that's why the live show is
important right exactly but then the
question is like how do you get more
people to to get to the live show so
we're still trying to find our tribe I
mean our fan base has grown tremendously
you know on a global level in the last
the the two years that blackout is
existed to the world but um we're still
trying to like crack that code you feel
me all right listen I'm on vacation
we're cutting commercials live from
Mexico we're on the beach damn it so
check this out man don't forget it's
summertime you got to go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg all
right that's gonna get you a free month
supply same active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis of course uh the best part
about Bluetooth is to get your dick
super hard what are we talking about
all right if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction through the stress
do the
I don't know whatever is going on
mentally it happens too you can get that
Ed fixed Bluetooth
promo code
bootleg three month supply bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to the family at
Odd Socks baby that's right shout out to
Odd Socks they got all kind of crazy new
licenses they just dropped uh man
Transformers they got the Hasbro
licenses now Power Ranger socks of
course they just did the Coca-Cola
earlier this year of course the most
comfortable socks in the world go to
oddsocks official.com use that promo
code bootleg and save 20 off
oddsoxofficial.com what has been the
biggest like uphill battle you think
that you've had to deal with in terms of
that because the music is so great it's
it's it's like we spend you know an
insane amount of time on the music and
the details in it storytelling
and um I guess the biggest uphill battle
has been like
the people that it does come across they
the the language is pretty consistent in
saying this is the best [__] I've Heard
right in in decades right this is like
this this reminds me right it's the best
album but
it's it's trying to get it in front of
more people and trying to figure out the
ways because like I'm so appreciative of
you like typing in with us because it's
tough to get people to like I thought I
was just happening with you I didn't
know there was enough yeah yeah so I'm
glad that there's an us yeah thanks yeah
um do you guys get that a lot by the way
yeah
every day I was like we try to keep the
project mysterious though that's what I
say you guys are like it's definitely
like you guys have a very mysterious
brand so I I guess you can't be
surprised if people don't understand
kind of the full Dynamics because if
they're just passive fans and they're
like yo I came because I mean you guys
have some some records that have done
well on the streaming side yeah for sure
um who would for you like would there be
any sort of like
dream collaboration that you are working
on or want to see happen soon within re
within reason you know everybody wants
to work with Andre 3000 and you know
see I knew it by the way he's got a new
album on the way Killer Mike said that I
was just saying I should on the way here
yeah
listen to the whole thing but yeah he's
incredible dream collaboration Andre
yeah I mean I I see it happening for
sure
um in Kendrick as well I see that for
sure coming through uh as far as like
production though because we're we're a
production dude we just finished
executive producing rhapsody's new album
oh yes and she's on and uh she's on this
album or the last album she's on this
one yeah two features shout out to
Rhapsody oh she's one of them ones
pretty much allowed [__] crazy and
you guys work with The Alchemist yeah so
what was that did you he handled the
full production on that one and you just
kind of did your thing out he sent he
sent the record
um I had sent him a joint
and I was like yo like I want to do a
switch up right here and I want your
beat to come in and I said to him he's
like yo the [__] that you have there is
crazy are you sure you wanna I was like
bro to work with you would be what we
need right so um he sent a bunch of
stuff back
and he's very hard to get in touch with
so um oh I know I didn't hear from him
for a while so we just threw some stuff
over it and um sent it back to him and
he was [__] with it through a couple
more things in it and yeah did you shred
over at some Alchemist
that was actually the song that I got to
shred over here nice crazy yeah yeah
it's them talking like having this like
psychedelic sexual conversation and
you're shred in the background yeah it's
disgusting would you consider I feel
like your music is very solid music to
shroom to
like I feel like I'm like a PR like I I
I I do enjoy mushrooms heavily yeah yeah
and I feel like when I hear you guys are
[__] I'm like man there's some [__] I
can listen to like looking at the stars
just [__] yeah tripping trying to
make it take you out there it's like
cinematic as possible so it's like you
guys are like the [__] Soulful Tame
Impala cause I didn't know Tame Impala
was one dude so it's kind of the
opposite right it's kind of like I
always thought Tame Impala was like 30
[__] when I found out it was
one guy my whole world melted yeah that
was nuts when I found out too I was like
this guy's a maniac
[__] it's crazy to him man so uh you
said Andre what you know what's crazy is
like has anybody from dreamville reached
out to you guys because I feel like you
guys are definitely like yeah you guys
should do dreamville Fest or something
I think we yeah they yeah I don't know
what happened I wanted to do that they
hit us up for some [__] I don't think I
went through somebody from dreamville
did reach out
um I got this weird superstition about
signing to artists I'm not even talking
about that I just mean like to work or
to collaborate I would love to and those
are the that's what I'm saying like
those are the kind of toppings like that
we would [__] like we would love to
have we just I don't know it just feels
like it
at this point I mean earth king yeah
yeah they typed in with us but
I've been wanting Nicole to see us for a
minute I don't know jid's incredible you
guys work with mariba right yeah mariba
is a part of a spillage village with
j.i.d and black and everybody so yeah
Marie was incredible [__] bro she's such
a good writer yeah she's been crazy on
ghost ride yeah she went nuts on that um
shout out to mariva um I was gonna say
uh there is I agree with you on your uh
point about not signing to an artist but
if there was an artist assigned to it I
feel like it'd be cool yeah because I
feel like Cole's done such a good job of
like high art Integrity artists yeah and
like he's so out the way that like when
you think of dreamville like you think
of cold but like now I mean dude jid is
a [__] massive Ari Linux is [__]
massive like you know like and I just
feel like he's done such a good job of
like him and uh Eve over there have done
such a good job of building like
high high level roster of talent that
isn't necessarily I'm signing you
because you got a [__] hot record you
know I'm signing you because I believe
in you yeah he's so different though J
Cole like I I he's a he's an anomaly
like for sure
he's part owner of the Charlotte Hornets
now yeah
Jordan sold the Hornets to a group that
includes J Cole it's [__] incredible
three billion or something crazy like
that
crazy upward Mobility man that's that's
a generational values building when you
guys are recording with all the
attention to detail you take
um what is the turnaround process like
like are you guys
does it take a week to finish a song
does it take two weeks to finish the
song just take a night like how does it
usually go
wow I don't know I feel like it happens
pretty quick it does but at the same
time we'll work on the same group of
songs like we'll bang them out and so
you kind of have like 80 70 of a song
done and then cool let's work on the you
know the guitar part cleaning up this
for 11 months yeah I'm just beautifying
it you know yeah like strings yeah
exactly yeah for sure is this your
guys's first tour since last year's
album so this is the two albums you guys
are touring on right here right yeah
this is our second yeah yeah the uh the
new album is out
um you've how many projects all together
did you guys have now this is our second
album second album okay
um and then you guys uh are starting
towards September yeah
um yeah so go support everything
um how do you guys spell your I mean for
people who don't know spell it out for
everybody people are stupid yeah
blk-o-d-y-s-s-y
yeah Cuban Odyssey coming soon I'm with
it I'm with it oh yeah dude you guys got
bit tired we did yeah yeah what happened
you guys got robbed in the bay huh so
they hit the window of the Sprinter bro
my mom had just flew in yeah
um well yeah we had just come from where
the [__] were we just stopped before
that
yeah probably Seattle Portland yeah
probably or Sack or something like that
yeah
Sacramento is what it was actually we
have my mama just wanted to watch us
play my shorty too and we uh
we went into a restaurant for about five
minutes didn't like the way the food and
the service looked so we left out and it
was already too late five minutes I went
and cleaned that [__] the quickest Lake
bro quickest [__] ever
suitcase hard drives with our whole
album wanted we have to restart did you
guys have backups yeah [__] oh I was
wearing the same underwear for the rest
of the tour well that's fine we didn't
have no bread you can't go to the store
and buy some new drawers no we didn't
have no bread
maybe that's why the sound guy wasn't
helping you out on tour yeah
just before we got with Empire though
okay okay
um have you guys ran into Joe Rogan
around town yet out there no no I ran
into Dave Chappelle on the trails
jogging though oh that's [__] great
that was crazy did you talk no no so it
wasn't like George Clinton really like
hey no I'm on the phone like hey I got a
I got an idea for album you should do
you know maybe these are imaginating oh
man heavy crazy [__] day we'll go get
the new album appreciate you guys go
check these guys out on tour uh go
follow them online black Odyssey thanks
guys appreciation
thank you brother yes sir hey appreciate
y'all watching another interview brought
to you by our good Folks at hardean now
listen y'all when you're in Las Vegas
you get in that [__] Uber you land at
the airport hit that taxi tell him to
take you to hard Dean the number one
premium cannabis dispensary in the
[__] world y'all I'm telling you walk
in they treat you like a king or a queen
or whatever you're into right they got
the craziest selection to premium
cannabis you'll see period anyway let
alone in Las Vegas but just anywhere all
right not only can you go get the best
tree you'll get the best experience the
best customer service the best bud
tenders you walk in the hard Dean and
that [__] just smells amazing they got
their own [__] scent literally you
get into my car I got a bottle of it my
car smells like Harding because it's
just the best [__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're gonna take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hardean all right you got
to go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank you all
man I love these guys they're like
family to us and hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love